before we actually approach the question
I just want to jog your memories when
you first learn about quadratic
equations and how to solve them okay we
learn we develop three methods for
solving such equations we're working
with them okay
the first kind because when we introduce
you we sort of ease you in and give you
nice neat quadratics which all have
pretty numbers what's the first way of
solving an equation like this starts
with an F factoring thank you okay we
give you nice neat stuff like this now
we say think of the pair of numbers that
adds up to five multiplies to six and
then off you go everything's nice and
neat and then of course if that were an
equation is equal to zero then you can
get the roots of that equation or
solutions to it just by reading off the
years okay after factorizing we learned
there's a whole variety of quadratic
equations that don't have these nice
friendly numbers okay and that's where
we pulled in this right that's what we
get to completing the square what kinds
of solutions are we looking for that
completing the square can get the
factorizing cannot we're good we're
looking for solutions that involve surd
okay because unless I mean I don't
usually go yes root 2 and root 5 will
work perfectly for this okay we don't
usually think intellisense so completing
the square is the method we use to do
that now that was in a stepping-stone to
develop the last technique the most
sophisticated one which was thank you
the formula right now hopefully you
remember that what you can do is take
the general quadratic equation you can
take this
and then you divide through by a in
order to make it Manik so the leading
coefficient is one and then you complete
the square and when you go from this I'm
sorry from this and complete the square
that's what the formula is that's where
all that - be customized etcetera comes
from okay so now I posed the question to
all of you if there's been this sort of
natural progression from here to here
and then here to here right why are we
going back what's the point if we've
like advance to past this kind of thing
and really completing the square was
kind of just a bridge to get to the
quadratic formula why are we bothering
devoting time to it
no any thoughts okay so a reasonable
kind of guess would be well maybe you'll
be useful for stuff other than finding
the quadratic formula does anyone know
what else that might be useful yeah okay
number one number one uh even if you
take something like this x squared plus
5x plus 6 equals zero okay we know we
can all factorize this all business
about that heart okay but I can still
actually do complete the square on this
right and so you'll get you know
something squared plus something else
right after you complete the square
right well this gives you an axis of
symmetry by which you can work out the
vertex and that's really useful so when
we do parabolas and Waka so the parabola
will develop all on this in more depth
okay
there's a simpler example that comes a
bit earlier than that which is a very
familiar shape this guy right now if I
were to give you an equation of a circle
what kind of information do we need to
describe this circle definitively
I need a point point I need where is the
center of this circle and I might give
you coordinates like say I don't know
maybe that's one too okay and then I
need one more piece of information
namely radius thank you so I need this
distance okay maybe it's three or four
or five or whatever okay once I've got
that information let's let me look at
this let's just call it four okay once I
have this information how am I gonna
write the equation of the circle how am
I gonna do it start with the center
right I'm gonna have X minus one squared
plus y minus two equals R squared which
in this case is 16 okay so this is all
nice and neat okay but usually you don't
get it nice and neat you get some
unmitigated disaster like this x squared
plus y squared by some random number of
X's and Y's over there okay so what you
have to do is recognizing that this came
from this you need to disentangle the
formula will not help you here okay
because you've got X's and Y's in there
constants all intertwined
okay the only way to find out what this
actually it come from is completing the
square okay so that's the point of this
this is revision but it's kind of not
really it's heading somewhere that is
most definitely preliminarily
so with that prologue in the back of
your mind how do we complete the square
what am I gonna do this thing
okay step one get rid of the constant on
the left hand side okay step two the
important parts are completing the
square part you take the B turn right
and / - right and you square it just in
case you missed that right exactly right
take the coefficient of x which is B
that's what we would normally call it
highlights where harvick square it
Harvey it gives us 4 square it gives us
16 and that's what we add to both sides
okay heads King us 14 over there happy
so that was the completing the square
part the reason why I was complimenting
squares was now that's a square I can
factorize this what is it X plus 4 all
squared right that's equal to 14 and now
I can proceed and I can solve right X
plus 4 should be equal to I need to take
both on the square roots okay and then
all I need to do is isolate the X happy
times
okay so completing the square we need to
be able to do in our sleep we need to be
able to do it twice within the same
equation and not get confused about what
constants we're adding together